if these things that we're experiencing
are the natural progression of what
happens when you do Seed Life on planet
or you do accelerate biological life you
do have some sort of a genetic
intervention where you take this thing
that it has emerging intelligence and
you accelerate it and that that thing
will in turn with all of its desire for
Innovation and creativity and also all
of its desire to control resources and
and have power and have influence that
it will eventually lead to the creation
of what we're seeing that these things
are the next stage of this process and
that maybe we're dealing with one form
of that next stage but there's another
stage that's a million years more
advanced than that that's far superior
that doesn't even have a biological
limitation in terms of physical space
that it exists completely in some other
undetect detectable realm that is not no
longer no longer thinks about biological
limitations of life and death and and
communication it exists completely in
some other space that that's what these
things are and that I I always wonder
when there's a crash or when there's a
body or when there's a this that like
and people saying well what if they're
so Advanced why are they crashing well
hold on which version are we looking at
we're we're not saying there's one thing
that's visiting us if there's one thing
that's visiting us and we know where
this one thing is we could say oh well
that thing it deals with a completely
different solar system that's not as
vulnerable it doesn't have asteroid
clouds it doesn't have all these
different things where it's like it
doesn't have a a planet that has super
volcanoes maybe life evolved in a more
stable environment and it allowed it to
get to a far greater technological level
but not the ultimate yeah we might be
testing the extent of their adaptability
and like I said are they crashing by
accident right Mission failure or on
purpose right well just think about
communication just are communication
used to be you had to get in front of
someone and they had to talk to them so
you had to know their language you had
to either non-verbal or verbal
communication you had to figure out a
way to say things to them that's no
longer the case obviously with this new
uh Android operating system it
translates but also the fact that you
could have a [__] FaceTime call with
someone in Japan right now and you
instantaneously can communicate back and
forth which is insane that's a vast
distance but for us it's like stupid
it's like yeah easy vast distance and
instantaneous that's like pong you know
that's uh that's a morse code that's
like it's very primitive in terms of
what if you physically can be in these
places instantaneous yeah and why why
would we assume that that's not
eventually going to be on the menu yeah
and of course friend of mine Eric
Weinstein certainly spouses we don't
even have the right theoretical
Frameworks right now you know he get he
he has his own geometric Unity Theory
and he's way smarter than I he's too
smart he has some his he's got some
unique theories himself about where all
the stuff is coming from and uh it's
it's all very very very interesting and
intriguing but also makes sense all of
it makes sense including being visited
you know I had this conversation with
Neil degrass Tyson he's like why would
they be interested in us I'm like what
the [__] are you talking about we're
super interested yeah Neil I mean
obviously he's a fine science
Communicator kind of the success of or
successor of kind of the Carl s kind of
I think Carl was a little bit more
openminded yeah I like Carl better by
I'm more of a fan wish he was still
alive I love to smoke weed that guy he
was really into weed oh really yeah
really really into it I have a theory
that the universe itself is
God I think that's like what I was
talking about with the you know
multi-dimensional Creator creating
universes yeah I think we have a very
limited idea of when we say God when God
created the heavens and like right right
but what is what what are we saying I
think it's the universe itself I think
it's one thing and that this one thing
it seeks to create these things that
continually push the envelopes and may
be Gods themselves eventually I think if
you extrapolate from our ability versus
the ability of an amoeba and you
continue to move that along what does
that do well it's going to be able to
create universes there's already been
theoretical papers that have been
written about the creation of other
things like black holes other things
like a universe the like what what is
involved in the creation of a universe
what is involved in the Big Bang can
that be replicated well not now but if
AI becomes sentient and AI eventually
makes far greater versions of itself if
it keeps doing that like what are the
limits of its potential creates a
simulated environment IND you can't tell
the difference between that and regular
life well maybe because there is no
difference maybe that is what I mean
that's the theory of simulation theater
yeah simulation Theory yeah familiar and
that that is a possibility cuz uh the
universe seems like a little too perfect
it's a little strange very created to me
so just like we're in the goldilock zone
perfect
temperature like it's how about the Big
Bang itself like what what happened
something smaller than the head of a pin
for for no known reason becomes
everything yeah okay and what's the
universe expanding into it's like a
quantum foam or whatever the heck the
latest theory is that's like Beyond me
and then it perhaps just retracts back
down to that infinitely small thing and
then expands again and that this is an
endless cycle and that we're just so
limited because of our biological
limitation
our life and death is such a small
little tiny blip it's so minuscule in
terms of just the overall known life of
the universe and then you have the James
web telescope that's you know there's
people that question the actual length
of time that occurred between the big
bang and now that maybe it might be far
longer and there's people like Brian
keing that say that's not that's not
correct it's just a a lack of
understanding of what we understand
currently about the of galaxies these
yeah because I mean obviously the length
of the the age of the universe keeps on
getting older and older and a lot of
that's because of the the Doppler fit
Doppler shift right the red shift as the
galaxies are accelerating away you know
we can calculate what the what what
their origin Point probably was and how
long it took for them to speed up like
that right so and only based on our
current understanding yes which is
obviously at least fairly Limited in
terms of what's its potential is well
yeah like we still don't quite
understand the origin of the Moon the
Moon is at the right location that
causes solar and lunar eclipses it's
like the right apparent uh size to block
out the sun it's like super weird same
thing with like Mars we're not sure like
what happened there where Mars you know
had some probable life on it either a
protoplanet hit it or there was some
kind of impact that vaporized stuff and
like who knows yeah who knows and this
is just this little tiny neighborhood
that we're looking at it's like we are
in our backyard hard looking for
evidence of like life in
Africa you know I mean you're not going
to figure it out here there's so there's
just we're just looking at such a small
scale in terms of what we could
potentially discover or potentially
observe yeah